South Africa is the only nation in
history to unilaterally disarm its own
nuclear weapons others have relinquished
theirs like Ukraine did but those were
Soviet weapons they inherited and not
their own home developed ones given that
no other nation has ever developed such
powerful weapons and then just decided
they didn't want them anymore this
raises the question why did South Africa
give up its nukes so first of all a bit
of background on South Africa by the
1970 South Africa's global position was
complicated the country was run by its
white minority in its government
introduced a social system known as
apartheid which means separation the
system restricted the black majority's
freedoms in the country these policies
towards the black majority in South
Africa meant that his relations with its
neighboring countries weren't exactly
great with the sole exception of
Rhodesia obviously as for its broader
international relations these changed
over time its relationship with the USSR
and the Communist world was always
terrible whereas its relations with the
USA in the UK were pretty good in the
1960s but as time went on they soured
early on the u.s. also had laws which
enforced segregation but when these laws
were repealed it became increasingly
less acceptable to maintain good
diplomatic relations with South Africa
and by the 1970s South Africa was
largely isolated things were made worse
when Portugal who had been covertly
supportive of South Africa withdrew from
its African colonies leaving it even
more isolated and it was this isolation
which led to South Africa developing its
own nuclear weapons although it took a
long time for the government to come to
this conclusion its thinking was that if
its survival were to be threatened that
none in the international community
would help it thus the only surefire way
of guaranteeing that the current South
Africa would see tomorrow was to build a
nuclear arsenal the mere existence of
which would deter aggressors so South
Africa had had its own nuclear program
since 1948 but this was devoted to
nuclear energy making economic use of
the country's abundant uranium deposits
in 1965 of the help of the USA it
commissioned its first nuclear reactor
and in 1970 Prime Minister John Vorster
authorized the creation of the uranium
enrichment facility although he stressed
that this would only be for peaceful
purposes exactly zero people believed
him
in the late 1970s events to the north in
Angola change government policy you see
Angola was undergoing a civil war which
had seen the intervention of Cuban
forces which were interned back by the
USSR South Africa saw this as a direct
threat to its very existence and so this
was when Prime Minister Peter Botha push
to develop nuclear weapons South
Africa's first nuclear weapon was
finished in November 1970
9 so by 1989 South Africa had seven
nuclear bombs of about the same
sophistication and yield as the bomb
dropped on Hiroshima an election in the
same year so Frederic de Klerk elected
as president in his priorities were to
win South Africa's international
isolation which would be done via
internal reforms to be blunt apartheid
days were numbered and it was his job to
make sure the transition away from it
wasn't to Civil War II this transition
would then bring South Africa back into
the international community which was
more important now that the Cold War was
over
you see prior to this the West could
tolerate apartheid South Africa because
it was fiercely anti-communist but now
the Warsaw Pact was dead the leverage
was gone there was also one other reason
you see with tensions running high the
white minority was worried about what
the next majority chosen government
would look like to simplify further the
white minority didn't trust a black
government with nuclear weapons and so
got rid of them with this inevitable
change coming - clerk thought the
rehabilitating South Africa would be
easier if his nuclear weapon program was
ended and in 1990 he did just that and
within a year all seven weapons had been
decommissioned two years later he
announced to the world that South Africa
had previously had nuclear weapons but
had also gotten rid of them South Africa
had just made history I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with extra thanks to these patrons you
can see on screen for their continued
support and an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologists
as ARCA Flash Danny Maloney party-boy
Koch coolin Castleman Rob Waterhouse
Chris wicker Gustav Swan David Silverman
Winston Heywood Christian checky Maggie
packs Kowski Lexi Schwinn Anthony
Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell Icke
spinning three plates are on the white
and Michael Reynolds